after news broke that ziploc bag full of
corn chowder Donald Trump is skipping
this year's White House Correspondents
Dinner Cathy doesn't have to be there so
we decided on our show to push for old
pal Anthony at a manic who's been doing
his amazing Trump impression you can see
the Trump Bernie debates on YouTube it
was like one of the biggest things we
ever did on the show so we said hey
maybe Anthony could do this you know to
fill in for the president by promoting
the hashtag make Anthony Trump again we
even we even got the support of Luke
Skywalker himself Mark Hamill Johnson of
course attended on Twitter seemed like
everyone was on board you know and
everyone everyone except for another
Trump impersonator famous actor and
longtime residents of your mom's mash
cache Alec Baldwin that was some reason
Baldwin who's doing an incredible Trump
on SNL and has been doing an amazing job
since last fall went on Jimmy Kimball
and was kind of dismissive of Anthony
and called him quote a guy who's on the
internet which makes Anthony sound like
he's currently stuck in Tron or
something he's a real guy he's done a
lot of stuff Anthony's an accomplished
performer he's been honing his Trump
impression since 2015 a little bit
longer than Alec Baldwin but fine I'm
not we don't want to battle anything I
don't you know I also not to mention the
two of them were on 30 rock together for
years here's Anthony now this whole
thing spilled over onto Twitter where
Alec was pretty dismissive of Anthony
and then when a random fan and our
friend James Adomian who played Sanders
in the Trump thing jumped in admittedly
Adomian was a little hot he was a little
hot but Alec Baldwin responded by
threatening to sue them
[Applause]
the CUDA drove this whole thing is Alec
Baldwin Twitter account blocked
@midnight TV show I didn't mean to be a
part of this I'm just supporting our
buddy
you know I first of all I wasn't
following him and he blocked me but now
I'm obsessing on now that I can't follow
him so I wanted to I'm black Alec I
thought we were friends
I didn't know I didn't know how as long
we want to do the Correspondents Dinner
and we're certainly not cheating on his
impression in any way to both do it one
of them get up and then roast the other
trumpet in swap places
roni Alec could just do the
correspondence in if you want if you
just go hey I want to do this Mako can
do it let's do it now who gives a fair
Alec Baldwin that's great toning is the
underdog here he is the Bernie Sanders
of Donald Trump
she'll understand it's taking things way
too personally threatening people with
lawsuits and then blocking me aka you
built a wall
so I don't want there to be any bad
blood here what can I say to get Alec
Baldwin to unblock me Steve hi Alec its
Lorne Michaels could you do me a favor
and unblock mr. Hardwick and while
you're at it maybe make an appearance on
the talking dead okay bye see you
saturday
all right great yeah right that's a
great thank you oh yeah you don't need
this you got that Alec Baldwin money yes
yeah he does Boulevard listen of all of
the Baldwin brothers you are absolutely
in my top three